democrats getting ridiculed for their
pathetic attempt at trying to give
president biden a pat on the back
despite soaring gas prices the
democratic congressional campaign
committee proudly tweeting out this
cherry picked chart showing gas prices
dropping by two cents over two weeks
even the washington post thinks it's
lame saying it might be the worst
defense of the biden administration yet
what jackass thought this was a good
idea and should said jackass be fired
well i think i should we should refer to
jessica to make the one great point
about how this all started so i don't
take it no
because i don't want to say so
she already talked about in america's
newsroom but what is funny about this is
it was a joke from matt iglesias who
founded vox he's a super lefty and
has a i very much enjoy his sub stack i
would say and he did it as a joke the g
triple c took it seriously it's been
retweeted by ron clean
it's a really bad y-axis
yeah like it's insane more like why not
access
um so that's a nice
little distraction to the whole thing
there were some good things the 4.2
percent unemployment rate is good i
imagine that the jobs number will be
revised like it has been the past few
months because 210 just doesn't sync up
with it i think we're at an average of
588 per month during the biden
administration which is good i know
we're coming out of a pandemic um but
that is the only thing is that the
administration has these allies like the
d triple c that's the basically the
campaign arm that tries to get democrats
elected to the house of representatives
and
you know
maybe somebody thought this was cute it
does there's no quality control whatever
and it seems harmless right but it
absolutely undermines all the
credibility everyone from the washington
post on down basically said this is so
embarrassing you should never be allowed
to do this again
not almost as embarrassing as the white
house talking about the july 4th your
barbecue is going to be 16 cents cheaper
than it was a year ago so greg they
don't know what they're doing i see i
actually appreciate this kind of thing
because it's a great lesson in data
manipulation we're living we're drowning
in data and all almost all of it is bs
because it's when the data comes out it
ends up being
manipulated in a way that it can't be
trusted so you see what this chart did
is that it zeroed in on the smallest
increase and created a line that appears
to be dramatic when in fact it's just a
tiny little thing
for example let's say you hear about a
study that says if you take the the
conclusion from this study is if you
take this pill it will cut the rate of
illness in half right but then you read
up and it was like it went from two
people in ten thousand to one person in
ten thousand so cut in half but it's
essentially meaningless that's how you
deal with data and and you it the best
thing you can do when you're is take
statistics courses learn how to read
stuff take an economics class if you're
young because then you'll be able to
laugh at this stuff and not get taken
well they did that with the coronavirus
yeah cases exploding 20 yeah case went
from four to six yeah something like
that exactly i don't know if the
democrats are dumb or they think the
american people are dumb if the
democrats are dumb that makes sense to
me right that would explain their dumb
policies i get that but if they think
the american people are so dumb that
they're going to see this and go oh joe
thank you i'm so grateful you know that
really pisses me off because it shows a
lot of contempt for the voters that oh
they're just not even going to look at
the fine print or they're just going to
scan through and see this and just be
deceived and there's a difference
between spin
which a lot of people do and deception
and i know that difference because
occasionally i will spin you do
occasionally you know what though it's
kind of like when people people get
taken by uh this kind of data game are
the same people that fall for like fad
diets like somebody who's like
people that are like into drinking raw
milk right well if you don't do your
research you might realize that raw milk
could be healthy all right to some
people
let let me continue
the way that you're going to see your
left-wing progressive diet that you're
peddling this is what this is like what
they did this is the scam this is like
when some 50 year old woman with obvious
plastic surgery tells you she's 25 and
she's never been under the knife all
right
that is
taking someone for a fool it's clear
she's been under the knife it's clear
she's not 20 years old that's what that
chart is all right the other thing is
too so when the price of oil and
gasoline was going up a dollar fifty in
the first what nine months of the buy
demonstration biden said he couldn't
control energy prices so then in two
weeks it goes down two cents and he goes
that was me guys so i mean can you
control it or not and it's also
what is so idiotic about bragging about
the decline in gas prices is it's
related to
supply so if you're in favor of
increasing the supply of of oil then you
should be in favor of pumping as much as
this nation possibly can yeah that's
what does right
they're basically um it's like they
cannibalize their own policy yes because
they're like uh we want to have high gas
prices because then you'll want to buy
electric vehicles but oh electricity is
also expensive oh okay so now we want
opec to pump more so that we can have
lower gas prices and it's like a vicious
circle cannibalization now there's a
doubt i mean they're very thin
you don't see a fat cannibal at all i
was just gonna say to greg's point i
think it's great now that people
actually in polls look at the crosstabs
and they see
what group has been over sampled and
make their own conclusions and now that
we have you're speaking
this is how i know you guys rigged all
those polls because i looked at the
crosstabs and you over sample democrats
like 15.
we won no but remember the poll in
wisconsin
trump was going to lose by 17 points
come on abc washington post how about
torelli in new jersey another yep pole
rigging extravaganza yeah and if a 50
year old is getting a facelift she's
really 70. so and she's never going to
tell you she looks 25 because she won't
she'll just look like she has a facelift
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else